they had me got the door locked behind
me and they're keeping me against my
will
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's so much it can't be that's
broken the damage
time please Spears met people who didn't
necessarily need intentional or
treatment of markers as many people as
possible
we were really encouraged to how to make
a story with sometimes to look more
severe on paper than a table we actually
won I made the comment you know it's
Texas it's not that hard to find good
never in my wildest dreams would I have
imagined that show keep common would be
the absolute
why they thought they were going to hold
me
I was walked down the long hallway where
human normally sees what I thought this
doctor's office is when they learned
that it was hospital rooms at that point
I realized - Pacific was it right
[Music]
I kept saying I'd like to access it out
like a second opinion I'd like to leave
I mean I call the police ask them to let
me go to let the police officer see the
paperwork they wouldn't tell them
anything they wouldn't tell me anything
[Music]
they just take you out of your life
and they hold you
[Music]
[Music]